this is a Fox News Alert I'm kimberly
guilfoyle and this is the five hurricane
Harvey a massive category four storm
will soon make landfall on the Texas
coast let's bring in Steve Harrigan who
is covering the storm from Corpus
Christi Texas really we've been watching
these conditions get worse the past
hours were all right now hitting
hurricane-force winds in parts of Corpus
Christi with a category 4 storm in
buildings well made happen and large
trees either snap or upper distorted
that here in Corpus Christi parts of the
building parts of a lot of slate
beginning to come off hearing some crash
we see some street lights down as well
so the physical destruction is starting
really like a ghost down out here right
now almost no one out of all doors
boarded up with fly
lashlines we've seen people fall debris
here grocery stores really patiently
find a job in their habit mandatory
evacuation in effect for a lot of
low-lying areas along the water some
voluntary evacuation
now they're not going to be able to go
out and help life-or-death situation so
those people who stayed are also some
people putting first responders flyers
at Red Hill question is what happens
down the road or massiveness you can see
some small things just fly through the
air here if that storm has expected sits
for a while that
the real heavy damage might still be to
come I toss it back to you all right my
goodness what an incredible shot and our
great reporting thank you so much for
what you do let's go now to Matt Finn
who is in blessing Texas with the latest
Matt hi Kimberly we are about 150 miles
north east of where Steve is the
conditions not nearly as bad here in
blessing Texas but they're changing by
the minute one minute there's blinding
win and rain and then it kind of settles
down where we are right now here in
blessing there was a mandatory
evacuation issued last night at midnight
the last buses to leave this county left
at 1:30 p.m. today so now law
enforcement officials are saying if
you're still here you're unfortunately
on your own this town looking like many
of the towns here in this area almost
entirely evacuated very quiet no one
wandering around there you know tweet
trees blowing in the wind and water
starting to pile up along the streets I
can imagine in just a couple of minutes
or hours it's going to begin to look
much worse here this is considered
ground zero some of the strongest
portions of the storm expected to hit
this area the National Weather Service
told County officials here a short while
ago they can expect 15 30 50 inches of
rain here in this county a mayor of the
neighboring city that were in said
they've never seen anything like this an
unprecedented amount of rain expected to
hit this area Kimberly back to you all
right Matt thanks so much and let's go
to rob Smith who is braving the storm in
Corpus Christi Texas
hey guys yeah welcome back to the party
here in Corpus Christi as I about get
blown over we are seeing I think about
60 mile an hour sustained winds right
now gusts around 90 we're about 25 miles
from the eye of this storm straight wet
this is I believe about as bad as it's
going to get for Corpus Christi right
here at this moment as we're kind of
touching pretty close to the eye wall of
this category for as we were right by
the water here this is shoreline
Boulevard here in downtown Corpus
Christi and we've been kind of watching
this thing develop all day long and the
interesting thing about this storm was
this wasn't supposed to hit till about
1:00 in the morning this thing just kept
on steaming right through the Gulf it
never slowed down and now we're watching
it make landfall something like five
hours earlier than we initially
anticipated and actually stronger than
we had dissipated you remember yesterday
we were talking about maybe a tropical
storm maybe a category 1 storm and here
we are today and we have a category 4
hurricane making landfall a major
hurricane the strongest storm that we've
seen I feel like if I jump up right now
you probably fly away strongest run
we've seen the United States in 12 years
so at this point damage is going to be
the big thing there's a hotel right next
to our hotel we saw the shingles start
to come off about an hour ago this
slowly just ripping off an old building
that looks like hadn't been well taken
care of and you're seeing the damage
from that now the palm fronds are flying
everywhere there's a lot of loose debris
flying around but the real question is
going to be the water in this storm
that's what everybody's really worried
about especially when you move to the
other side of this storm right now we're
on the west side of this hurricane I
guess you would say on the east side and
the north side of the hurricane the
dirty side is where that water is really
going to build up and when this thing
stalls out and it sits over you know the
South Texas area and especially up into
Galveston Houston on that dirty side as
it stalls out it's just going to dump
rain for days and days and days it's
going to create a mess and that's going
to be the real story after right now
which is the wind which we're dealing
with as we speak guys we'll send it back
to you in studio okay Rob we have a
couple follow-up questions if you can
bear with us but some so you talked
about the water levels there that
they're really worried about that
anticipating some you know major concern
what are they doing in terms of trying
to prepare places buildings etc
facilities so they don't sustain
intensive water damage well we haven't
seen a lobby I haven't seen many
sandbags we've been moving around Corpus
Christi quite a bit I mean the one thing
they do have obviously during the Gulf
they're ready for this kind of things
they have this seawall right here which
I believe is either twelve or fourteen
feet high they're expecting somewhere
between a six to twelve foot storm surge
so that's one way they're going to try
and handle it but as far as the rain
that comes from the storm the rain that
dumps from the sky I haven't seen much
evidence of preparation at all I've seen
a lot of boarded up gas stations and
retail stores and stuff like that
anticipating the wind but as far as
flood control I really don't know how
they're going to handle that and I
haven't seen a lot of preparation for it
now it could be that I've missed it but
we've driven around this is not a big
city we've driven around I haven't seen
the sandbags I haven't seen the flood
preparation but it's the Gulf they're
used to a lot of water here I mean
that's the way it is down here so does
it seem robbed that people have been
heating the public safety warnings of
the officials there telling them to stay
inside and about what time did you
notice that it really was clearing out
yeah there's nobody here I mean our
hotel has got you know maybe fifty
people in it most of them involved with
the media there's no cars on the road
people did this is not this is not a
mandatory evacuation area right here but
if you go just a little bit closer to
the coast because right we're kind of on
a Bay here but if you go out onto the
little stretch of islands that kind of
make up the Gulf Coast out there
anything between the Intracoastal in the
Gulf Coast they had to get out it's
mandatory so I would assume they're all
out most of the people here are out too
I mean people are just going to play
with this I mean when it started to turn
into a cat three cat 4 hurricane
I think people said ok you know it's
screw this we're gonna get out of here
and rightly so I mean this is a serious
storm all right well obviously we want
you to take care of yourself there and
protect yourself from the elements and
probably checking back in with you later
Rob thanks to that update yes sir all
right let's bring in chief meteorologist
Rick Rypien from the Fox News Weather
Center to get the very latest Rick thank
you yeah it's about 300,000 people in
Corpus Christi so it certainly is
decent-sized city the storm has slowed
down in his Ford progression that's bad
news
you'd like it to move on and get out of
there it's not going to happen to be
with us as Rob was saying for the better
part at five to six days not at this
strength but it's going to take a long
time for a hundred and thirty mile an
hour storm to begin to wind down in fact
we might not really see that for the
better part of say 36 hours or so one
should notice Kimberly this year last
year they launched a new satellite up
into the atmosphere is called goes 16
this is the first time we've had a
hurricane that we've seen with this
imagery we get an image every five
minutes instead of every 15 minutes and
it creates a much more accurate and
potentially hopefully life-saving
picture but to get an idea of this storm
right here you kind of see this doughnut
you see the center of that eye a lot of
times when the server's begin to
interact with land they start to
breakdown that has not happened at all
we've had a strengthening storm all
afternoon a strengthening storm allows
the winds that are high up in the
atmosphere to transport down to the
ground a lot easier and that means that
we are going to see probably these winds
at 130 gusting to a maybe 155 miles an
hour and that is about to happen in fact
the outer eye wall or the inner eye wall
is now coming onshore here in the South
Padre Island winds here it already about
an hour ago being clocked at about 110
miles an hour and that was before we had
this eye wall coming onshore we won't
say there's a landfall until the center
point here crosses land that still
probably maybe an hour to away because
it's moving so slowly want to show you
this this is one of the computer models
that we look at the weather models that
we like we trust this one a lot and here
we are right now with a landfall you go
about 24 hours from now we still have a
hurricane just around 50 miles or so
inland that's Saturday go into Sunday
into Monday morning still the center of
a storm here around Corpus Christi right
where Rob is go into Tuesday into
Wednesday you get the idea we still have
this storm here it is not until maybe
Thursday or so that it's gone in some
models indicating now that the storm
actually might just kind of dissipate
over the next say week week and a half
here that means all of that moisture
that is up in the atmosphere is going to
fall down across this area and
that is why we're so concerned about
this catastrophic flooding how much rain
National Weather Service has been saying
things like 35 inches I've never seen
the National Weather Service put out a
forecast like that that said this same
model that we're looking at take a look
at some of these number 53 inches here
that's from kind of Corpus Christi north
we'll move that map a little towards the
north go to Houston and we're talking
about numbers that are pushing 20 inches
so everywhere in between that's about a
250 mile stretch we're talking maybe 1
to 2 feet in some spots 4 feet or so go
inland as well San Antonio maybe 10
inches Austin 8 inches this is kind of
that cutoff line if it goes any farther
towards the west
we're solidly into Hill Country and
major damage there anywhere to the east
that no doubt you're in it so everybody
getting the rain a lot of people getting
the win and I actually didn't even talk
about the storm surge today which is
going to be with us all night long and
because of that continued onshore flow
it doesn't go away right away fact a lot
of that storm surge 12 feet might be
with us for a couple of days
my goodness staggering factors including
the amount of water fall you know
expected from this and range really
considerable all right Rick thanks for
that we'll be checking back in with you
okay let's take it around the table Dana
Fersen comments well when he said that
Port Lavaca could get 53 inches of rain
I'm 60 inches tall oh not that tall then
I mean that's a lot of rain oh if I
could say so I've been watching over the
past couple of days in particular today
I think we have the most skilled and
talented weather team and also they're
very brave maybe slightly crazy the
graphics are amazing the other thing
though is that they help explain they
tell a story and they have really big
hearts like they've been really trying
to tell people how to take care of
themselves so I think that our coverage
Fox has been amazing and so it looks
like because the storm is going to be so
bad you need to stick with the channel
for through the weekend
no absolutely it's going to be extensive
and as they say continuing into next
week you just really see how courageous
they are to put it on the line to bring
it to our viewers really being in the
eye of it in order to do that Jessi our
heart goes out to the people of Texas
especially there along the Gulf Fox News
loves Texas Texas loves Fox News
everybody in America loves Texas anybody
that's spent any
I'm down and that part of the country
knows how great the people are and you
know how they're going to come together
for the cleanup because they're going to
weather it and then the cleanup is going
to be the worst part so it's nice to see
cut you know and they hate when I see a
natural disaster happen but it's great
because it brings the country together
and it unifies the country in a way that
sometimes the other things don't more
than sports more than you know a
terrorist attacks when a natural
disaster happens in America churches
families the feds the governors
everybody comes together and it's a
beautiful thing to see just about the
team - Harrigan Steve Harrigan getting
low to the ground bending the knees
deserves combat pay this guy Rob Smith
over there in Corpus Christi looks like
he was having the time of his life out
there reporting in a category four and
that's been great job you know like you
said great team out there I just can't
believe how quickly this thing's been
upgraded and hope everybody stays safe
and I just can't believe that given your
waters world name you're not out there
enemy out there actually there's oh I
would love to make a bet with you and
then end up with you as a hurricane oh
wait what happens if you lose can I use
my power I'll go the hurricane okay very
dangerous bet is like scary good though
Juan get your thoughts well I'm just
worried about a sharknado you know but
all this water coming up off the ocean
you never know what's in it can write
you never know what could be in it so I
mean is your work not for she's just for
contained water yes I feel like yo stop
say one of the interesting things to me
just looking at it is how come there's
not a mandatory evacuation you can be
there and the government says no problem
I just think that's why I guess in that
one particular area where Rob was but he
was saying you know to the side of it
over there that they would no no he was
saying on the island Corpus Christi you
saw haired and there a look to me like
the other guys Rob said he would look
like if he just because a storm but when
we'll go ahead from a 1 to a 4 no no but
Harrigan was right there in our hour and
I'm saying he looked like he could say
he was going to get knocked over we know
that Governor Abbott has called for an
evacuation especially for those in the
low-lying areas in the coastal areas as
well but we also know that that is
somewhat contradictory to what some of
the local areas have said I know the
mayor
Houston has said something a little bit
contradictory to that not urging people
to leave like Governor Abbott has but
you know we certainly pray for those
individuals who have decided to wait
this storm out praying for their safety
and you know well thankfully we have a
brave team there as Rob had mentioned
all 50 people or he had said you know
what I think 50 people in the hotel
they're all waiting yes yeah that is
often they party we're the only lunatics
that show up for it